okay so all of us are dead it was a
great zombie show set around a high
school that has outclassed many in the
genre due to its drama and core
principles it'll no doubt go down in
history due to the geography of korea
that it uses to its advantage and due to
it being the number one netflix show
around the world we don't have to do the
math to figure out it'll be back i'll
stop with the crap school puns for now
though and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down our big
theories on it this includes what the
half beast could be doing in the next
season what happened to chong san and
also the big villain i think could be
emerging that was teased at in this
entry but before we get into it just a
quick word from our sponsors who helped
to make this video hey you you punk
should have been listening for a second
yet for the next minute or so i want to
talk to you about the best mobile game
around rage shadow legends it's
something i play whenever i'm on the go
or if i'm hiding out somewhere all day
waiting for the zombie apocalypse to
blow over if you played it before then
you'll know how good it is and if you
haven't then they've just added a whole
new load of challenges this includes my
brand new favorite boss sir galaroth the
guardian of the arcane keep when he's
not trying to smash your face in like
you should smash the like button he's
actually a pretty nice guy who's been
tasked with protecting the arcane keep
this is so that the arcane potions are
only accessible to those that are worthy
and that means he's gonna put you
through your paces to get them you gotta
use your brain to beat him up but a
little tip i wanna tell you is that his
basic attack strips you have your buffs
so the best way to beat them is to keep
the aoe buffs on your team at any cost
seems pretty straight forward but it's
made more complicated by the boss's left
minion which will strip you of them
every time it gets a turn so just take
him down first or use the control
debuffs to take him out the fight
there's never been a better time to play
as rider's got a ton of things happening
this month with a fresh new rotation of
the brutal hydra boss there's also
events and tournaments every day
including some special valentine's day
ones where you can get your hands on a
brand new legendary champion this is the
best time to get started in raid and if
you click my link in the description or
scan my qr code on screen you'll get
some cool bonuses too your uncle kevin
spoilers is giving him away and this
includes an epic free champion 200 000
silver one energy refill one xp boost
and one engine shot so you can summon
awesome champions as soon as you get in
game all this treasure will be waiting
for you there i'll see you in raid
shadow legends
cheers okay so season one ended in a
great place for season two to pick up at
the end the students are in a state of
limbo as they're left a quarantine
despite the army leaving anjo still
reeling from the death of chong sang
explores the abandoned zone and notices
a fire on the school roof it's
significant as namros said should they
meet again that they should have a
campfire together anjo and the rest of
the group head to the school roof and
here they get a reunion with namra she
explains how there are more like her
that run away from the school and heads
off in quite dramatic fashion by jumping
off the building setting up a superhero
landing now throughout the show they
pretty much bucked the trend of the
amling slow zombies and because of this
they could take the series in a
refreshing new direction in season 2.
with namurai saying that there are more
like here and seemingly heading off to
them who would say that the zombie
outbreak is in a state of cold war and
chiang san could be one of the people
out there that's turned into a half bee
i'll talk about him more later on but
there is a lot of evidence to support
him still being alive now season 2 could
explore how namra and her kind live out
there in the wilds whilst the human
story expands as the students try to
make a life in the quarantine zone
having these two clear divides in
society could lead to a political
fallout as we saw the government are
happy to exterminate the half bees just
for existing sure they want to turn the
lunch lady into a lunch lady but they
have powerful abilities that could aid
humanity so it's a bit of a political
political quandary in which the humans
will likely want to take back their
homes whilst the hobbies will want to
continue existing i think the core group
will get caught in the middle of this as
they're more on the side of namra rather
than the people that left them behind to
die from a political viewpoint
assemblywoman parkian he was asked to
resign so it's no doubt that the army
and politicians will feature again
trying to fix the fallout from the
pandemic i also think that there will be
a resurgence from the virus as it'll be
impossible to keep locked down if the
undead are still out there i think that
the science teacher likely survived the
bombing and though we never got it
confirmed he's probably a half b2 he
might be the person that wants to start
the virus up again as in many ways his
theories were right he thought that
there was a way to create a new
superhuman and though it failed on the
most part if one had the will they could
defeat the virus now before we speculate
about what could happen in season two i
have to clarify it's not been confirmed
as of yet however there is a lot of
evidence to support that it is on the
way we know that netflix notoriously
loves to cancel things more than a
twitter mob okay dramas are incredibly
popular and after the dizzying culture's
success of squid game streaming services
decided to double down on korean content
they are leasing two facilities in south
korea and have spent 700 million dollars
on shows from the country in the last
five years they've committed to many
many new k-dramas and according to the
analytics site flix patrol it's the
number one show worldwide believe it or
not it even beats social media
juggernaut shows like euphoria and the
bugger bob effect for twitter engagement
on the week it dropped thus i do think
it will avoid the fate of things like
cowboy bebop and jupiter's legacy and
that we will definitely get a season 2
at some point as for chung-san though we
never see him survive or turn into a
heartbeat i do think that he's out there
in the quarantine zone the series made a
point of showing greenham reviving after
almost every single death which set up
the rules that the half beats are
incredibly resilient and in some cases
they regenerate over time he and guinem
are fully engulfed in flames as the
missiles hit the school and therefore it
could be taking him a while for the
healing process to finish if he survived
we could see the group of hafiz trying
to make a new life for themselves and on
the opposite side of these the
authorities could be wanting to take
them down stuck in the middle could be
the students trying to defend them and i
think that would add a really
interesting dynamic to the second season
the half beast would be the key to
taking back the city if they can work
out a way now to go feral just like
namurai did in the final episode they
can survive death as they're already
technically dead and can wipe out the
zombies themselves aiding humanity the
story of the half beast versus the
adults would fit well due to the fact
that the show is really about the
societal pressure to succeed that is put
on the students and how they feel
abandoned and let down by the adults the
school turned a blind eye to the
bullying and even when the crisis
started to escalate all they cared about
was the school's reputation not the
safety of the students further on the
trend of them being let down by the
adults even the virus itself was created
by a teacher and therefore it all ties
together into this overarching theme
upon reaching the quarantine zone the
kids even say that they were abandoned
and anjo insists that you'll never do
anything for an adult again while anjo's
dad did come back to save her it wasn't
at the behest of the authorities and he
had to break every law in order to
escape they were quite literally
abandoned and it's a theme that spread
throughout the show with even yunji
being failed heavily by everyone around
here whatever happens the kids will need
to defy the adults if they're gonna live
a free life and i can definitely see
that being a theme that carries into the
second season while the epidemic is
being contained for now it's not out of
the realm of possibilities that it can
re-emerge and come back again even worse
than before the decision that led to
bombs being dropped was made due to the
fact that the undead was spreading out
into the wider country or at least the
threat of them doing so with the idea of
the harpies out there it's likely one of
them could give in to their base or
instincts and bite someone in a
different part of the country which
would start the outbreak again whilst
the bombing was done to put a stop to it
all namra's words at the end of the
season do indicate that the whole
situation could just repeat itself again
it's a common trope with outbreaks
occurring again such as 28 weeks later
and land of the dead it would make for
great watching if the zombies have
somehow reached the capital of south
korea making for even higher stakes than
we had in season one one big looming
mystery over the show is that the virus
itself is still largely an enigma we
know that lee wanted to do something to
teach his son a fight back against the
bullies but his son had given up on life
after observing predators in their prey
he found that the ladder would be
fearful but sometimes they'd fight back
and he took it upon himself to create
something that raids us of our flight
instincts the harpy versions seem to
have a virus that has the human and
monsters part fight against each other
and whoever is infected with this
wrestles back and forth lee spent a
while trying to investigate the virus
and why it did what it did and if there
was any way to cure his sudden wife some
efforts to slow the virus sort of worked
but ultimately they were given to the
disease and become zombies the virus
mutated to hide in people and make them
look like normal humans as a survival
technique and season two could explore
what's next for the disease it evolved
over what seemed like just a few days
meaning that in the four months between
then and now it would have no doubt
evolved even further this could mean
tougher zombies but it could also
heighten the effort in searching for a
cure while the incubation period is
unknown most of the half beasts turn
pretty quickly and the quarantine zone
gives an insight that the scientists
haven't made much headway in forming a
cure season 2 should spend some time
exploring this as i found the research
in video diaries from lee some of the
most interesting parts of the show now
one thing that was left unresolved which
could be touched upon in the future was
the detective and also the streamer the
stream is set out someone needs to
uncover the real truth which as we know
is almost impossible to get from our
governments these days the detective
made it to the safe zone but i'd also
like to see him again in season two
investigating what's really going on
with the virus whilst there's not too
much left to explore about the origins i
mean we pretty much have seen the whole
thing through the video diaries left by
its creator it will create an
interesting subplot for the series
moving forward and obviously i'd love to
hear what you think will be happening
next time so comment below and let me
know we are in a competition right now
and giving away three copies of the doom
box set on the 28th of feb and all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the season we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want emails to watch then make sure you
check out our breakdown of whether chong
sand survived which will be linked on
screen right now we go over both him and
guinam's fate and analyze every scene so
it's definitely worth checking out right
after this without the way thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
you've been the best i'll see in the
next one take care peace